Land und Brecht
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Morgen in die Runde
ja guten Morgen video podcast wir haben
ein Gast Richard
war ich ausgesprochen bei ist bei uns
ihres Zeichens Forensikerin wir beide
kennen uns ein ganz kleines bisschen sie
waren schon zweimal glaube ich noch bei
uns in der Sendung habt ihr schon mal
getroffen
und wir wollen heute ist Sommer in
Deutschland ähm alles luftig alles
fluffig alles locker alles leicht eine
gute Gelegenheit um mal über was richtig
düsteres zu sprechen über das Böse zu
sprechen sie sind Forensikerin
ja genau ich frage ganz Bewusstsein ein
bisschen leihenhaft damit wir zusammen
mal verstehen was sie eigentlich machen
und mal ganz platt für mich
runtergebrochen sie befragen jeden Tag
Menschen treffen Menschen die schlimme
Dinge gemacht haben
sie begegnen sozusagen jedem Tag den
bösen na ich begegne also wenn ich
explorationstermine mache die habe ich
natürlich nicht täglich also nicht 30 im
Monat aber übertrieben
ich begegne Menschen die Straftaten
begangen haben mehrheitlich eben schwere
Gewaltstraftaten also aus dem sexuellen
und aus dem nicht sexuellen Bereich also
Tötungsdelikte das breite Spektrum von
Sexualdelikten von Missbrauches
Vergewaltigung
auch brennstiftung und so weiter aber
schwere gewaltige liegt ja auch Gewalt
der liegt im öffentlichen Raum und wir
haben ja zwei spuriges Strafrecht das
heißt wir kennen Straße zur Tat Schuld
für eine aus der eigenen Verantwortung
heraus abzuleiten Straftat und eine
Maßregel der sogenannten Besserung und
Sicherung in der Psychiatrie für
Menschen die aufgrund einer schweren
psychischen Erkrankung und die muss
schwerwiegend sein
schulfähig sind oder schulunfähig sind
ich habe zwei Kliniken geleitet von 2000
bis 2018 für forensische Psychiatrie
also psychiatrische
hochsicherheitskliniken und habe mich
jetzt vor fünf Jahren selbstständig
gemacht weil ich nur noch meiner
Sachverständigen Tätigkeit nachgehe und
das heißt ich untersuche Menschen in
Bezug auf die Frage ob eine Straftat mit
einer schweren psychischen Erkrankung
zusammenhängt ja oder nein das hat
Auswirkungen auf die Frage wieder
Schulfähigkeit und ich mache sogenannte
Risikoprofile also
gefährlichkeitsprognostische
Gutachtens Männer mit denen sie dann
sprechen
92%
wieder oder wenn wir den wieder
rauslassen wie groß ist das Risiko dass
er dann wieder vergewaltigt wieder
Morgen und wieder wieder auffällig wird
sozusagen und eine eine große Gefahr für
die Gesellschaft ist das hatten sie in
ihrer in ihrer langen Zeit in der sie
das machen mal irgendwann das Gefühl
heute habe ich etwas gehört das ist das
ist das ultimative Böse
nein es ist ja nicht meine Blickwinkel
also ich setze mir ja nicht die Brille
auf wo auf den Brillengläsern irgendwie
der Aufdruck das Böse steht oder gucke
ich dann durch ne
Straftaten sind für mich in der ersten
Linie
Ausdruck eines menschlichen Schalters
und alles
scheitern alles Menschen an seiner
eigenen Biografie und an seinen eigenen
potenzielle Lösungsmöglichkeiten
dass die Dinge böse sind oder dass die
Dinge die mit denen ich mich befasse
nicht toleriert werden können ergibt
sich aus den Delikten selbst ich
beschäftige mich ja nicht mit Kaugummi
klauen sondern mit schwerer
Gewaltkriminalität insofern bedarf ist
ja meiner Moralisierung überhaupt nicht
weil das ist selbst erklärend
Menschen
sind ja nicht 365 Tage im Jahr böse
sondern sie haben ein Potenzial dass ich
unter bestimmten inneren und äußeren
Bedingungen realisiert und dass ich mit
anderen mehr oder mit einer hohen
Wahrscheinlichkeit noch mal realisiert
und insofern sitzt mir ja immer ein
Mensch gegenüber der wiederum die
meisten Eigenschaften hat die ich auch
habe und der nur sehr klein Teilen eben
von diesen Eigenschaften abweicht
interessieren haben Eigenschaften jetzt
etwas genauer weil die scheinen ja sehr
unterschiedlicher Natur zu seiner wir
kleben nachher das Etikett das Böse
drauf aber es gibt ja sehr
unterschiedliche Motive aus denen heraus
Menschen Verbrechen begehen und da finde
ich hilfreich aber das sehen Sie
vielleicht anders oder viel
differenzierter als ich das Schlechte
und das Böse zu unterscheiden das
gleiche macht man ja auch im englischen
ja da kann man also Bett und will
unterscheiden
und unter dem Bösen unter evil verstehen
wir eigentlich einen Sadisten also
jemand der eine eine psychische Störung
hat und der Spaß am Gewalt am Quälen am
Beginn von Verbrechen also
wahrscheinlich ne ja richtig bösart hier
sofort dorben bis ins Mark oder sowas ja
also dem das Spaß macht dem nur der
Spaßfaktor am Bösen klebt das ist ja
wahrscheinlich wenn man sich die
schweren Straftaten anbelangt man
relativ kleiner Prozentsatz ganz klar
und der größere Teil besteht ja aus aus
dem Motiven dass jemand aus einer
Verzweiflung heraus was gemacht hat oder
dass jemand traumatisiert ist und dann
oder oder in seiner Kindheit die schon
massive Gewalt erlebt hat und deswegen
so dieses Gewalt Raster in sich hat oder
ähnliches und wenn wir sagen er hat
schlechte Taten begangen tun aber schwer
damit zu sagen das ist ein böser Mensch
ist ist diese Unterscheidung von von Bad
und evil also Bad etwas Böses tun nicht
unbedingt aus einer bösen Gesinnung
heraus und ihre wirklich böse Gesinnung
seiend ist das für sie eine
Unterscheidung die sie auch treffen
das ist insofern nicht mein Gegenstand
weil als Sachverständige bin ich
natürlich extrem neutral und ich bin mir
dessen bewusst dass man forensischen
Psychiatern gerne nachfragt das
Psychiater für alles und jedes
Verständnis hätten Verständnis im Sinne
von etwas nachsehen das ist nicht meine
Aufgabe ich sehe nichts nach so wie ich
auch nichts vor sehe Gegenstand meiner
Begutachtung geschlichtweg das an
Verhalten was Gegenstände
Strafgesetzbuches ist und das sind
schädigende Handlungen gegen Dritte wo
die Integrität
Dritter grob missachtet wird
und wo es unterschiedliche Motive gibt
und da bin ich bei ihnen im Sinne des
Bösen oder das tragischen es gibt
Delikte die speisen sich aus einer
schweren brüchigen
persönlichkeitsfehlentwicklung wo
derjenige selbst getan ein
schicksalsträger ist und es gibt andere
die begehen Delikte weil sie perfide
Absichten haben also
konkurrenzausschaltung immer bei
tuttungsgeld bleiben sie können
unendlich viele Motive finden Leute zu
töten und da ist es so kann man ja
denken schon also
von Eifersucht dass er das hoch
emotional ist geht und besitzt Streben
das wäre ja das ist ein sehr
narzisstisches und Konkurrenz
Ausschaltung das wäre was perfides also
ja Ehre zum Beispiel
dann gibt es natürlich historisch neu zu
definieren begründe also zum Beispiel
kriegen dürfen sie töten vorbei ist
dürfen sie das gleiche nicht mehr tun
also es gibt bereicherungsabsichten habe
hier nein
sexuelle Lust ganz ganz ganz selten aber
es ist ein Motiv das heißt es gibt ganz
unterschiedliche Gründe und sie sind
gewissermaßen unterschiedlich tragisch
in der Person verankert ich habe sie
haben mehrere tolle Bücher geschrieben
ich habe sehr viel davon auch gelesen
und habe zum Beispiel einen Fall jetzt
gerade im Kopf
den sie mir mal erklären müssen also
gibt es eine Frau die hat ein Liebhaber
und weil sie nicht in der Lage ist ihr
Mann zu sagen ich möchte mich von Dir
gerne scheiden lassen und begründet das
auch so und sagt weißt du ich würde dich
damit verletzen und die Kinder und so
weiter und sofort beschließt sie mit
ihrem Liebhaber diesen Mann einfach
umzubringen
ja was passiert da das sind die
sehr speziellen problemlose Strategien
ausgesprechen registrionischer Frauen
für mich populärwissenschaftlich
hysterisch
also diese Persönlichkeit dieser Frau
ist
sozusagen wenig kompetent offen ehrlich
und konstruktiv aber auch durchaus
emotional belastend Konflikte zu lösen
ja und sie möchte eigentlich sie lebt
eigentlich in einer Traumwelt wo sich
das das Ungemach in dem Fall dass er
noch ein Ehemann hat irgendwie in Luft
auflösen soll also es soll sich alles
einfach wie in einer Märchenwelt von
einer schönen Zauberfee auflösen aber
das funktioniert natürlich nicht und
dann bringt man ihn halt um und dann
gibt es so eine Gemengelage das ist eine
perfiden Art von Innigkeit dass man so
denke ich wenn jetzt mal diesen Ehemann
immer genial einfach Hugo also hugo ist
im Weg das wäre eigentlich schöner wenn
Hugo gar nicht mehr da wäre aber hugo
ist nun mal da ist auch ziemlich gesund
und vielleicht auch noch Sport also es
kann auch lange dauern und dann denke
mal so ah wie wäre das denn wenn Hugo
wenn Hugo ein Unfall hätte und dann
einfach Stürme boah das merke ich dass
das wirklich gut also wenn der einfach
weg wäre das Beste für uns moralische
Abkürzung
und dann schaukelt sich das auf und dann
ist man dabei zu sagen eigentlich
könnten wir dem Unfall etwas nachhelfen
zum Beispiel und dann diese
Überschätzung man wird uns nicht drauf
kommen und es ist die es ist die Idee
sozusagen ich will nur einen
fingerschnip machen und ich bin jeder
sozialen Verantwortung auf der
internationalen auf der Beziehungsebene
letzten Endes ledig wäre sie haben
anderes Beispiel dass die schildern wo
sie sagen da gibt es diesen Mann der
lebt in diesem Haus mehrere Parteien
völlig unauffällig lebt dann völlig
unauffälliges Leben ein sehr netter ein
angenehmer Nachbar einer wie man in sich
wünscht nur ein einziges Mal
flippte aus und geht dahin ersticht
seine Nachbarin aber bringt sie nicht
direkt um sondern er zieht ihr den Darm
sozusagen bei lebendigem Leib aus dem
Körper und wickelt in ihr über den Kopf
ja das ist ein in der Tat ungewöhnlicher
Fall das sind das sind das sind die
Dinge in ihren Büchern die mich immer so
verstören denn dann kommt sozusagen die
ganze wissenschaftliche Ebene wird das
alles sehr sehr genau erklärt dann sagen
sie ist auf das Böse als solches gibt es
in dem Sinne gar nicht wie alle können
auch zu solchen Dingen plötzlich fähig
sein und Leute die sowas tun sind
eigentlich von uns vom Rest sozusagen
gar nicht so furchtbar weit entfernt ist
eigentlich auch eine Frage der Umstände
und dann kommt plötzlich so mit einem um
mit zwei Sätzen kommt da so ein Ding so
ganz nebenbei mit einer Brutalität das
springt ein förmlich an und dann machst
du ja genau deswegen macht Frau seine
diesen Job und ich besser nicht
also die Geschichte dahinter was die
Geschichte dahinter ist ja völlig klar
er ist doch völlig klar dass
ein Mensch der das tut und wir drei die
wir jetzt hier sitzen und diesen Diskurs
hier führen dieses Gespräche führen dass
wir uns in ganz fundamentalen Dingen in
unserem Leben davon unterscheiden das
ist uns völlig klar also
wenn sie in ihrer Persönlichkeit nicht
ein
bestimmte Impulsivität haben wenn ich
dann bestimmtes cholerisches Temperament
haben wenn sie vielleicht keine schwere
Suchterkrankung haben wenn sie nicht
abnorm kränkbar sind dann haben Sie
schon eine ziemlich viele relevante
Faktoren nicht um irgendwann
vergewaltigt zu werden also schwere
Gewalttätigkeit hat ganz häufig etwas zu
tun entweder mit aktiver Gewalt Bejahung
als also sozusagen einen ein mindset wo
ich Gewalt einfach ein Preis als legitim
verhaltensspiel und problemlos lösen
oder oder Interessen Durchsetzung
Impulsivität pathologische Krankheit
zu schnell beleidigt schnell beleidigt
sein genau
und
Feindseligkeit im Denken zum Beispiel
das sind alles Eigenschaften geringe
Selbstwertgefühl mitunter das sind alles
Eigenschaften die Gewalttätigkeit
befördern jetzt in diesem Fall war es in
der Tat Sohn das ist ein sehr seltener
Fall auch dieses Verletzungsmuster so
sehr sehr sehr ungewöhnlich ist
das war ein ein ehemaliger Metzger das
war ein sogenannter kopfschlachter und
ich habe mir dann sagen lassen dass
dieser kopfschlachter normalerweise in
einer Stunde 60 Schweine zerlegt hat
also pro Minute ein säugetierkörper
und das muss man also wissen wenn man
diesen diesen Modus operieren sieht und
er hatte er war ein chronisch
Alkoholiker und er war das muss man
sagen glaube ich ohne ihn jetzt
persönlich zu nah zu treten er war
ein extrem einfach strukturierter Mann
also jemand der nicht in der Lage war
über innere Gefühle und Wahrnehmung
letzten Endes zu reden also eigentlich
ganz ganz simpler Typ der im Grunde
seiner Arbeit hatte und wenn er Freizeit
hatte dann hat er gesoffen und das war
eigentlich sein Leben also arbeiten und
saufen er ist auch nie bei der Arbeit zu
spät gekommen ist immer zur Arbeit
gegangen ja aber und ansonsten hatte er
viele Bekannte die auch sehr viel
getrunken haben und er hatte eine
stehende Redewendung und zwar wenn er
Karten spielte ohne das Gefühl hatte
dass jemand anders ihn irgendwie über
den Tisch ziehen wollte dann hat er
gesagt pass auf ich ziehe das geschlinge
aus dem Arsch und hängst dir um Hals das
war dann stehende Redewendung
und irgendwann ist er zu dieser
Nachbarin und was da genau war das
konnte man nicht konnte man nachher
nicht rausfinden
wahrscheinlich gab es irgendeine
sexuelle annäherungssituation und diese
Nachbarin war auch stark betrunken
Todeszeitpunkt hatte die drei Problem
und ganz ausgemalt Alkoholikerin und
wahrscheinlich gab es irgendeine
körperliche Annäherung es gab irgendwas
mit Rücken Einreiben mit Franzbranntwein
und
irgendwie Dinge und dann dieses Delikt
er hat darüber so nichts gesagt
und aber irgendwann jemals was darüber
sagen wird das weiß ich nicht
aber das war sicher etwas an ein
impulsiver Durchbruch von etwas von
einer wie sexualisierten Kränkungen habe
ich mir relativ sicher aber das blieb
offen das heißt das kann plötzlich
ausbrechen aufbrechen er hat eine
bildhafte Vorstellung davon gewissen der
also wenn sie mich jetzt persönlich
fragen würden ich würde Ihnen schon
deswegen die
das gedärmlich aus dem Bahnhof
rausziehen weil ich keine innere keinen
inneren handlungsentwurf dazu haben ja
nicht dass das geht
aber genau also ich müsste es geht und
dann Bilder zu wie es aussieht aber es
wäre nicht Bestandteil meines inneren
handlungsentwurf ist weißt du sozusagen
ist insofern sind aber er hatte ja
diesen er hatte dieses innere Bild und
zwar bei ihm eine stehende Redewendung
das heißt es war ein also eine
Deformation professionell möchte ich was
sagen weil er ja ein Handlungsmuster
hatte was er über Jahre und Jahrzehnte
seine beruflichen Tätigkeit auch
eingeübt hatte und
im Zweifelsfalle tun Menschen eben das
was Sie was Sie tun können was mich
jetzt interessiert ist steckt das
irgendwie in jedem also frei nach der
ersten allgemeinen Verunsicherung das
Böse ist immer und überall ja nur wir
haben mehr Schutzschichten darüber oder
ist es etwas das nur in ganz bestimmten
Menschen vorkommt ich frage das deswegen
sie haben ja gerade gesagt bei jenseits
ihres Berufs wurde das jetzt keine
wirkliche Rolle spielt aber wo sie sich
viele Gedanken darüber gemacht haben
Gewaltdelikte sind existenzielle Dinge
die man tut ja sie haben das selber so
existenzphilosophisch geschrieben indem
sie gesagt hat wer wir trennen im Grunde
genommen diese diese Distanz von der
Welt die heben wir auf wir kommen eine
Art Rausch rein wir leben eine Art
Lebensintensität das können wir guten
und das können wir wahrscheinlich auch
im Bösen erleben ich sage das deswegen
weil ich habe ja mit Jane Goodall mich
mal lange unterhalten und
es ist halt so dass sie sagte es ist
unheimlich viel Gutes sind champanzen
beispielsweise noch viel Böses in
Schimpansen und wenn man sieht und da
gibt es ja auch eindrucksvolle Bilder
wie die Schimpansen überwiegend die
Männchen wie die andere Affenarten jagen
und die dann Leben zerreißen und in
einen Blutrausch geraten die sind außer
sich den geht einer ab wenn die diesen
Affen zerreißen und sich mit Blut
verschmieren und so also irgendetwas
davon scheint ja im Menschen vorhanden
zu sein dass durch den zivilisatorischen
Gürtel durch unsere Erziehung finden wir
tausend Möglichkeiten das nicht
rauszulassen sondern andere Wege zu
finden aber vorhanden nach dieser These
wäre es eigentlich in jedem Menschen
also jeder Mensch wäre quasi zum
Äußersten in der Lage wenn die Umstände
ihn dazu bringen oder wenn die ganze
Schicht die darüber liegt wenn die
bröckelt würden sie das Unterschreiben
also könnten wir alle irgendwann in
einer bestimmten Situation zu Mörder
werden jemanden also die Frage ist ob
unsere Lebensumstände
so desastrieren das tatsächlich alle
unsere Schichten komplett bröckeln
würden also potentiell ja aber ich
glaube der Unterschied ist wie viel wie
viel Schichten hat man entweder drüber
also sozusagen wie
viele Mädel ist
und wie sind die die historischen
Umstände also man weiß ja wir wissen ja
alle aus dem Dritten Reich das völlig
normale Bürger
unfassbare Dinge getan haben in KZ
Familienväter Säuglinge an die Wand
geschmissen haben getötet haben und man
denkt wie kann das sein als als
Familienvater auch noch also selber
eigene Kinder haben also die Situation
Amon Gült zum Beispiel und andere die
einfach zum Spaß aus dem Fenster
schießen die Menschen vor ihren Augen
umbringen und dann reingehen in die
Wohnung das Abendgebet sprechen und
ihren eigenen Kindern über den Kopf
streicheln
neben solchen Sadisten
nun wirklich ne einen schweren Schaden
ja ähm das auch eben ganz normale
Familienväter wir nehmen diesen Podcast
hier in Hamburg auf ja ganz normal
Geschichte eines Hamburger
polizeiparteiens davon hat es mehrere
gegeben
die eingesetzt wurden zur Verstärkung
der SSS im Holocaust die zu einem sehr
großen Teil aus Familienvätern bestanden
weil die nämlich zu alt waren um die
Wehrmacht eingezogen werden das heißt
die meisten von denen hatten Familien
und die so Stück für Stück in den
Holocaust reinkamen und da
offensichtlich ein Mechanismus Griff
nämlich am Anfang gab es ja die eine
oder andere Situation wo der ein oder
andere vielleicht Probleme damit hatte
also jetzt hier jüdische Städel quasi
auszureichern ja also die die Männer
zu deportieren und die Frauen und Kinder
zu erschießen aber wenn man das einmal
gemacht hat oder zweimal oder dreimal da
irgend so ein
verrohrungsmechanismus gegriffen hat
sicher auch alles immer verbunden mit
sehr viel Schnaps trinken und Alkohol
und so weiter aber es hat funktioniert
und es hat immer und überall
funktioniert und dann ganz wenige Fälle
sind überliefert dass es nicht
funktioniert hat das ist ja noch viel
viel
also seit dem Prozess gegen den 60er
Jahren die diese Polizei und diese Leute
die davor Gericht standen
aber da kommt was hinzu
wir haben ja in befriedigen
Gesellschaften in der Regel zu tun mit
Eltern als Individualität älter ja
üblicher mit dem
sprechenden gesellschaftlichen
politischen Auftrag sondern der hat
selber ein Thema mit sich und macht dann
irgendwas
bei solchen Männern ist es ja so das
geschieht in einem vorgegebenen
politischen Kontext unter einer
Ideologie und dann gibt es
unterschiedliche narrative für die die
Menschen anfällig sind Pflichterfüllung
ich hatte meine Befehle es musste sein
es war notwendig und es wurde gesagt
dass es notwendig ist also Befehl und
Gehorsam wir konnten ja nicht anders und
die anderen haben ja auch es war es war
vorhin es war in Ordnung genau es war in
Ordnung also das was normalerweise
überhaupt nicht in Ordnung ist weil
jetzt in Ordnung es ist eine Umwertung
der werte ich habe gleich eine
Einwendung aber es ist eine Umwertung
der Werte und es ist auch eine
narzisstische Gratifikation also die
meisten Menschen tun eigentlich nichts
wo sich nicht nachher irgendwie mal
besser fühlen und wenn man sowas dann
schon tun muss obwohl man eigentlich
vorher nicht auf die Idee gekommen wäre
dann muss es sozusagen
der einer demagogischen macht gelingen
den narzisstischen Selbstwert darüber zu
stabilisieren also zu sagen du tust
etwas besonders wichtiges
du übernimmst eine besondere Aufgabe für
etwas Abstraktes großes und ein
Volkskörper
es muss gemacht werden Pflicht Erfüllung
ist ein ein hohes hat eine hohe
narzisstische Gratifikation und auch
selbst Überwindung hat eine hohe
narzisstische Gratifikation
ja das sind alles diese Dinge und mit
denen wird ja auch ganz systematisch
dann gearbeitet und nur wenn sie
im anderen sich selbst sehen oder der
oder besser gesagt sich selbst im
anderen erkennen
ist es im Grunde so dass sie das nicht
tun und und von Mohammed ATA der auch
einige Berühmtheit erlangt hat
September hier in Hamburg studiert und
dann genau Florida Flugschein gemacht in
einem der Tower rein
geflogenes Testament geschrieben das ist
von einer amerikanischen psychologischen
Stein sehr auseinanderklamiert worden
und der hat
geschrieben an seine Mittäter sie
sollten sich nicht mit dem Gedanken
befassen dass die Leute die jetzt gleich
sozusagen Opfer des Attentat sind dass
das Familienvater sind und Sie sollten
nicht ein Vergleich zwischen sich selbst
und den Menschen die dort arbeiten und
die jetzt ausgelöscht werden muss nicht
darüber nach was du da ja und das zeigt
eigentlich dass ihm ja vollkommen klar
war je mehr ich im anderen mich selbst
erkenne ja
dass du mit mehr sinkt die Bereitschaft
etwas zu tun also etwas Haustieres zu
tun und alle
destruktive Ideologie fängt immer mit
der dhumanisierung an menschlichung und
wir haben auch hier in der Gesellschaft
entmenschlichende-humanisierende
narrative oder das ist nun
bei Anfang der der Kurve Pandemie
untergegangen aber es gab auch im
öffentlichen politischen Diskurs ja vor
wenigen Jahren zum Beispiel diesen Satz
man solle reiche wenn man das auch ist
man solle Reiche der nützlichen Arbeit
unterziehen und da viel mehr spontan ein
historische bekanntes Tor ein ähm jemand
hatte gesagt man muss an die Wand
stellen und dann sagte ein Politiker hat
die Wand stellen müsste man sie nicht
aber man müsste sie zu nützlichen Arbeit
daran ziehen da sind wir ganz ganz ganz
nah bei einer relativen Dritten Reich
ist das ist aber verplätschert weil wir
zweiter Tage später den kompletten
ersten Lockdown hatten und
ich empfehle Ihnen sehr in der in der
Mediathek können sie sich das noch mal
angucken
der Mann der sozusagen maßgeblich daran
beteiligt war der war vor einiger Zeit
bei uns in der Sendung sie haben genau
darauf angesprochen Linkspartei vor
allem Parteitag in Kassel wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere und dann sagt er
irgendjemand die Reichen alle mal die an
die Wand stellen und Riexinger sagt naja
vorher wollen sie noch mal ordentlich
für uns arbeiten lassen also muss ich
gleich an die Wand stellen ich habe ihn
darauf angesprochen und zwei sichtlich
unangenehm und ich habe auch seine
Entschuldigung sehr
akzeptiert und und einverstanden war
damit einverstanden als keiner dem ich
unterstellen wird das ein schlechter
Mensch ist aber diese Art zu denken
diese Art zu reden das nicht sauber
abzuräumen das fand ich in an dem Punkt
natürlich schwierig und ist offenbar
sozusagen eine gewisse ja auch an dem
Punkt wieder Ideologie ne es geht mir
nicht um schlechte Menschen also genau
schlechte Menschen egal ich kann auch
keine es ist mir auch völlig wurscht
kennen Menschen
mindestens keinen der sich selbst für
einen schlechten Menschen
keinen schlechten Menschen
nicht interessiert
sondern mich interessiert
diese Denkweise die nun wirklich ja auch
eine sehr historisch bedeutsame Epoche
der Weltgeschichte
eingeleitet hat und diese Denkweise ist
von Übel und damit meine ich das Böse
diese Denkweise ist von Übel das ist
eine der Humanisierung dass man Menschen
die Menschenwürde abspricht nur weil sie
irgendeine ziemlich marginalen Punkt
eine andere Eigenschaft haben oder eine
andere biografische
ein anderes biografisches Feature haben
oder eine andere Hautfarbe oder
sogenannte andere hätten hier sind oder
was auch immer
alles Unterscheidungsmerkmal kann
jederzeit überall zu der Humanisierung
herangezogen werden
will ohne dass ich ihn jetzt verteidigen
muss ja das muss ich in keinster Weise
aber wir haben sehr kritisch damit
auseinandergesetzt und es war halt die
Chance das wirklich mal zum Thema zu
machen war gar nicht geplant aber wir
kamen dann darauf und da musste auch
länger aufgehalten
Bernd Riexinger nehme ich ab dass ein
dem Moment versucht hat als
Parteivorsitzender eine unangenehme
Situation irgendwie zu retten ist
gründlich schief gegangen und hat es
auch mit dem völlig falschen Satz
gemacht aber ich nehme ihm das ab das
erste der erste Teil ist der der mich
schockiert hat weil da genau diese
Ideologie klar wird von der sie gerade
sprechen das steht jemand
Nachwuchskraft und sagt die reichen die
gehören alle an die Wand nein sind
beides sind beides es beides das gleiche
Problem für mich entsteht überhaupt
keinen sondern vaginaler Unterschied das
mag verwundert mir ist schon klar wo der
Unterschied oder lebenslasse also es ist
mir im Alltag schon klar es ist für mich
aber moralischen in dem Falle ein
insofern marginaler Unterschied weil
indem ich schon sage man muss jemand zu
nützlichen Arbeit daran ziehen ich bin
nun weiß Gott sicherlich jemand für den
Arbeit als Feature von Selbstwirksamkeit
eine ganz große bürgerliche Bedeutung
hat also es geht mir nicht um das Weg
Definieren von Arbeit es geht mir aber
darum dass nicht jemand anders
berechtigt ist zu definieren was ist
nützliche Arbeit schon das ist eine
immense Anmaßung und in dieser Anmaßung
definiere ich schon wieder welches
Individuum ist nützlich insofern ist für
mich das zwischen an die Wand stellen
und die nützliche Arbeit in dem Kontext
liegen für mich sehr sehr nah
beieinander aber markus hat ein bisschen
auch auf die Situation hingewiesen genau
dazu sagen also ich nehme an dass der
Sinn der Übung in der Entschärfung des
ersten Satz des verstanden hat und wir
Markus richtig tief genug
interessiert bei diesem Polizeibericht
noch was anderes
Pflicht ist und wenn es heroische Sache
ist dann sind die Leute bereit sich
innerhalb kürzester Zeit zu der
humanisieren was ja schon mal eine
erschreckende Nachricht ist die
Sozialpsychologie die sich mit diesem
Fall ja ausführlichst beschäftigt hat
stellt ja noch was anderes Fest wir
sagen es ist nicht nur die Pflicht
sondern das ist dass man nicht aus der
Reihe tanzen will also der Konformismus
noch nicht mal die chirurgische Sache
bei dem auch ich will nicht derjenige
sein weil die berühmte Geschichte bei
dem Polizeibataillon war ja bei dem
allerersten Einsatz dieser Hamburger
Polizisten die da nach Polen gebracht
worden waren hat er zuständige Polizei
mal joa major Trapp die Leute etwa 500
Polizisten die Wahl gelassen ob sie sich
eine Massaker beteiligen oder nicht das
ist nur ein einziges Mal so weit wir das
überhaupt wissen in der gesamten
Geschichte des Holocaust des vorgekommen
dass die Leute vor eine Wahl gestellt
wurden und er hat gesagt der von euch
oder derjenige der meint er könnte da
nicht mitmachen der drehte einen Schritt
vor und jetzt hätte das bedeutet aus der
Reihe zu tanzen er hat ja nicht
umgekehrt gesagt diejenigen die Bock
darauf haben treten mal einen vor
sondern diejenigen so und dir wenn man
die Reihe an einem ist innerhalb von
Sekunden zu entscheiden man ist das
Kameradenschwein dass ich gedrückt hat
und so weiter abgesehen davon dass ich
wahrscheinlich beim ersten Einsatz viele
noch gar nicht vorstellen konnten was
das eigentlich mitgemacht und was das
konkret bedeutet aber dieser
Konformismus genau ist doch sagen wir
mal wenn man nicht das Böse ja weil
niemand unterstellt dass die diese das
gerne gemacht haben
ja genau aber das Schlechte was ich da
ereignet hat 1800 Menschen die da
umgebracht wurden überwiegen Frauen und
Kinder dass das in diesem Moment die
dieser Sekunde Entscheidung war das nur
die Frage wie stehe ich vor meinen
Kameraden da und nicht die Frage ich
versündige mich an der Menschheit ich
bringe ich mache Dinge die ich nie in
meinem Leben jemand erzählen kann ich
Hande gegen alle Prinzipien gegen meine
Erziehung gegen meine Bildung gegen
Religion und das ist doch merkwürdig
oder dass man denkt so wie dünn ist die
Moral aufgehängt oder verankert ja wenn
sie so einfach auf jeden Fall auf den
ersten Blick so einfach aus so eine
profanen Motiv ja der niedersinken kann
und durch was anderes überlagert wird ja
das ist ja auch noch geschickt gemacht
nicht zu sagen also wer nicht mitmachen
möchte tritt vor interessant wäre ja auf
was wäre gewesen wenn jemand sagt wenn
ihr nicht diejenigen die nicht mitmachen
wollen die treten
gar nicht ein ins Auto genau
die sammeln sich dahin
so irgendwie das heißt auch in dieser
Rhetorik ist noch mal was manipulatives
gewesen und ähm das der
Konformitätsdruck das ist natürlich was
was wir heute in anderen friedlichen
Kontexten in der Gruppe Dynamik von
Gewalttaten haben ja also wenn Sie wenn
Sie Gruppen Vergewaltigung haben ja also
diese sogenannten Gangbangs wo Gruppen
auch immer irgendwie einer irgendwie
innerlich denkt das ist jetzt scheiße
was da abläuft aber der nicht aussteigt
Vergewaltigung im Krieg auch dass er gut
das ist ja noch mal ein anderes
Instrument auch das ist ja auch noch ein
strategisches Instrument aber nicht für
den Einzelnen der daran beteiligt ist ja
nein nicht für den Einzelnen der
beteiligt ist aber sonst strategisches
Instrument um den Feind zu humanisieren
und was natürlich das macht ja auch nur
Sinn durch tiefe Tiefe Verankerung
patriarchalischer Gedanken weil da ja
Haus und Hof und gesindet zum Besitz des
Mannes gehören und der Feind ist
männlich und indem ich sozusagen die
weiblichen den weiblichen Besitzstand
also das rational funktioniert ja
sowieso nur
bei denen die da alle mitmachen da
können ja ganz liebe jetzt in die Jungs
dabei gewesen sein die sich nie in ihrem
Leben hätten vorstellen können ich
jemals eine Frau zu Vergewaltigung
solchen Situation wo alle anderen
Kameraden das auch machen und
möglicherweise auch eine Menge Alkohol
im Spiel ist Dinge tun die sie sonst nie
alleine getan genau und da kommt meinen
jetzt zivilen Bereich wieder das Thema
der risiko-prognose und der Prognose
Begutachtung weil es da natürlich auch
darum geht nicht mehr sehr viel mit
Sexualstraftätern zu tun
also das Rück von Risiko individuell zu
bestimmen
ob jemand sozusagen im Rahmen meiner
solchen Gruppendynamik singulär zum
Straftäter geworden ist oder ob das ein
feststehendes Verhaltensmuster ist es
einfach auch ein
festreißen lassen oder ob das sozusagen
an einem ein festes Muster ist trotzdem
noch mal eine Frage die dieses
Polizeibericht ich erinnere mich an
lange Gespräche mit Sally parell dessen
Geschichte irgendwann verfilmt worden
ist Hitler junge Salomon den kann ich
recht gut weil wir zusammen mal eine
Dokumentation gemacht haben über diese
wahnsinnige Geschichte und ich bin dann
verschiedene Punkte seines Lebens
begleitet und er erzählte unter anderem
seine seine Eltern waren dann irgendwann
von Peine die waren kleine Schuhhändler
und Verkäufer und sind dann geflüchtet
Richtung
in Polen dort gab es an sehr sehr großes
jüdisches Ghetto da fühlte man sich
einigermaßen sicher als es in peinlich
schon alles sehr sehr unsicher war und
sehr sehr gefährlich war und erst dann
irgendwann als klar war okay auch das in
Lodge wird böse enden in diesem Ghetto
die werden uns alle umbringen sagen samt
und sonders auf Bitten seiner Mutter
einfach geflüchtet mit seinem Bruder an
der Hand einfach Richtung Osten lauf
einfach bis du irgendwann der roten
Armeen die Hände fällst und dann wirst
Du zumindest nicht von den Nazis
umgebracht das ist in Kurzform die
Geschichte da öffnen sich dann noch
unglaubliche Dinge und es gibt
wahnsinnige Wendungen in dieser
Geschichte aber was mich interessiert
ist seine Eltern glaub sein Vater ist
ein Typhus verstorben irgendwann seine
Mutter wurde dann irgendwann die war
noch gesund in den letzten Kriegstagen
auf einen dieser LKW gepackt
indem sie Abgase eingeleitet haben und
dann fährt er einfach los und natürlich
hatte dieser Mann seinen Befehl aber die
Entscheidung irgendwann den Motor
anzulassen alles hermetisch abzuriegeln
da hinten drin sind Frauen Kinder die
wenig später anfangen werden um ihr
Leben zu zu schreien ja wie sie noch nie
in ihrem Leben gerufen haben und du
fährst einfach erbarmungslos weiter bis
es leise ist diese Entscheidung triffst
du ja ganz alleine die haben für diesen
Job nicht berühmte Sadisten ausgewählt
also nicht hingegangen und hat alle
pathologischen verbrecherz hat man die
eingesetzt genau aber jetzt in diesem
Situation ist das ja auch wieder ein in
Anführungszeichen ganz normaler Mensch
der das meine ich während der und da
kommt der Punkt also du könntest sagen
der Motor ist nicht angesprungen du
könntest sagen die Haare war irgendwie
kaputt du könntest sagen mir war
irgendwie schlecht du könntest sagen ich
habe es nicht übers Herz gebracht ich
weiß von Berichten auch Auschwitz zum
Beispiel es war mitnichten so dass Leute
die nicht bereit waren andere
umzubringen die nicht bereit waren das
zu tun was sie von beschrieben haben
kleine Kinder an der berühmten Rampe
Babys einfach zu nehmen und an die Wand
zu hauen bis sie sich nicht mehr bewegen
grauenvolle Sachen es war nicht so dass
den irgendeine Sanktion droht wenn sie
es nicht gemacht haben also man hatte
dafür ein gewisses Verständnis unter
Anführungszeichen gesagt okay der kann
das nicht ist okay hat keine
Konsequenzen
Beispiel dass jemand deswegen erschossen
wurde trotzdem macht das trotzdem trifft
er diese Entscheidung was ist das für
Sie also für mich ist die Frage
natürlich wie viel an
militaristische abhärtungsideologie auch
vorher schon in der Bevölkerung war in
der Gesellschaft war
und
insofern die Härte
wiederum eine ein
Feature der narzisstischen Selbstwert
Stabilisierung ist also sozusagen der
harte unerschrockene mitleidlose Mensch
Synonym gesetzt wird für den starken
Menschen und Menschen wollen im Leben
stark sein auf irgendeiner Art und Weise
als körperliche das heißt mental oder
beides und damit arbeitet das auch also
ich denke das eine ist das
die selbst Überwindung auch wieder
eingebettet ist in eine
gesellschaftliche in ein
gesellschaftlichen kommenszenz wo das
anlocken kann wir haben heute
glücklicherweise noch in der Bevölkerung
ein anderen gesellschaftlichen breiten
kommenzins wie wir sein wollen so dass
wenn jemand sich hinstellen würde sagen
würde irgendwie ich kann kleine Kinder
an die Wand schlagen das macht mir
nichts
würde man heute glaube ich nur in einer
Randgruppe Applaus ernten aber
mehrheitlich würde das kann aber ganz
schnell kippen nehmen so und das ist das
ist einfach der Punkt ja ich glaube die
Frage ist was was haben wir für
narrative die Menschen in ihrem
Selbstwert stabilisieren und
sozusagen die
naja man kann natürlich auch sagen gut
wenn ihr das macht mit geht ja auch
innerlich ein gewisser Art von
menschlichkeitssuizid ja das ist also
natürlich auch eine indirekte andere
Form sich selber zugrunde zu richten
aber die die narzisstische Gratifikation
scheint mir ein starkes Element zu sein
für destruktives Handeln ich habe
Berichte gelesen habe gesagt zum Teil
selber erfahren wenn Sie heute in die
Ukraine reisen um mit
Soldaten dort sprechen die von der
Frauen kommen die zeigen Ihnen ohne
große Aufforderung zeigen die genau
diese brutalen Videos enthauptungsvideos
Menschen die bei lebendige kastriert
werden und und all diese Dinge
grauenvolle Geschichten junge Männer ja
die plötzlich sozusagen noch Sexualität
quasi im Kopf fühlen aber sie nie wieder
im Leben ausleben können und die dann
irgendwie für den Rest ihrer Tage damit
umgehen müssen ja Menschen die bei
lebendigen bleibt einfach enthauptet
werden geschichtet werden wir wie ein
Schaf irgendwo das ist unvorstellbar und
was ich festgestellt habe ist es ist
nicht so dass das in irgendeiner Form
der ultimative Tabubruch ist die
Abschreckung sondern da entsteht dann so
ein gewaltporno der immer weitergeht und
diese Leute die wollen das Erzählen die
brüsten sich damit das ist den wichtig
das ist so viel andere wie möglich
erfahren bis zu dem Punkt an dem sie
dann irgendwann sich selber
möglicherweise einfach aus dem Fenster
stürzen weiß ich nicht mehr aushalten
genau ja also das ist ja ein
eindrucksvolles Bild für diese frauung
die hier offensichtlich schnell
eintreten kann bis hin dazu dass eine
gewisse Gewalt Faszination kommt und
diese gewaltfaszination die scheint ja
den Menschen jetzt nichts grundsätzlich
fremdes zu sein also ich muss ja ein
Grund geben warum aber von dem deutschen
Mattscheibe jeden Abend tausende von
Menschen sterben also jeder vierte Roman
der in Deutschland verkauft wird ist ein
Krimi wenn man sich anguckt wie hoch die
Krimi Quote im deutschen im Fernsehen
ist und wenn man sich anguckt wie brutal
Krimis sind mal verglichen mit Krimis in
den 60er 70er Jahren und so weiter wir
brutal überhaupt Filme allgemein
geworden sind also die Faszination an
der Grausamkeit und so weiter muss ja
etwas sein was sehr sehr viele Menschen
für sich irgendwie nachvollziehen können
ist doch merkwürdig dass etwas was wir
so negativ beurteilen ja wie
Gewaltverbrechen genau sich gleichzeitig
einer solchen Faszination zu Hause auf
dem Sofa erfreuen wie ist denn das
überhaupt erklärlich das müsste doch
eigentlich was sein wo sagt dass ich
nicht sehen das ist das Ding ist
eigentlich ein feststehen der Begriff ne
das ist die Faszination des Bösen die
Faszination des Grauens die scheint ja
zu geben mensch das ist die Frage ob sie
Statistiken haben ich habe sie nicht
deswegen ist es nur auf eine Frage von
mir ich würde ja behaupten dass die
Faszination für
Gewalt sehen wobei die Krimis geben
öffentliche rechtlichen Fernseh laufen
aber
das ist
sehr raffiniert geworden
also
dass das ein Aspekt ist wir haben eine
wir leben in einer Gesellschaft
alles dafür tun oder so bleibt das nicht
für selbstverständlich
die sehr sehr befriedet ist sie haben
selber gesagt die Gewalt Community
faktische gewaltkomität ist sehr stark
zurückgegangen Gott sei Dank und das
heißt im Grunde erleben wir eigentlich
gar nicht wirklich Gewalt als
Massenphänomen in der Gesellschaft das
heißt es wird sowas abstrakte während
wenn wir in Länder deswegen frage ich ob
sie Statistiken kenne ich kenne sie
nicht sonst selber dort
höchste Mordrate der Welt
wahrscheinlich finden die das im
Fernsehprogramm gar nicht so raten
scharf aber wenn die morgens irgendwie
aus dem Haus treten haben sie schon in
den ersten Toten von der Tür das heißt
ja das kann ich sagen nein Formulierung
ukrainischen Soldaten ob die jetzt noch
Lust irgendwie auf dem Grill hätten also
wahrscheinlich eher nicht ja
oder Sie haben sozusagen wirklich das
war mein Eindruck wirklich verstanden
in der Form wie sie normalerweise zur
Verköstigung verboten wird in Krimis
oder so zu konsumieren aber was ich als
Rätsel bleibt für mich ist ja nach wie
vor die Frage warum in befriedeten
Gesellschaften das Interesse an
virtuellen Morden so groß ist da habe
ich noch keine Antwort drauf weil es das
andere ist auch immer das katharische
ist selber sicher zu sein und es ist es
stirbt fiktive stirbt noch nicht mal
real im Krieg stirbt real jemand anders
für einen selber das ist noch mal eine
Unterschied aber in so einer Serie dann
am Film stirbt fiktiv jemand in einem
Spiel für einen selbst wenn man selbst
ist ein Stück weit davon gekommen ne und
dann gibt es eine harmlose
Projektionsfläche man kann sich also mit
dem Opfer identifizieren und man kann
sich mit dem Täter identifizieren und
das geschieht nichts also ich kann mich
die ganze Zeit im Krimi mit dem Tablet
identifizieren Komma aber selber nicht
vor Gericht also das sind glaube ich
unterschiedliche Facetten und dann auch
wir leben in einer Gesellschaft in der
der Tod ja nicht mehr stattfindet also
viele Menschen haben ja noch nie im
Leben eine Leiche gesehen und es kommt
ja zu absur
Situation
im Gericht wenn wenn dann Zeugen geladen
werden die dann beschreiben das was sie
sich jemand tut auf der Straße lag oder
und dann sagen sie seien davon schwer
traumatisiert die Aussage kann man ja
nur treffen wenn man relativ weit vom
Leben weg ist und
das heißt
es ist auch eine
Faszination
sich mit dem Tod auseinanderzusetzen der
eigentlich nicht stattfindet was eine
spielerische Art und Weise
interessant die nehmen Zusammenhang nur
ganz kurz Klammer auf Klammer zu
Sebastian Fitze und auch Adler sagen
beide berühmte Krimiautoren die sich
hier die übelsten Dinge ausdenken für
Frauen kann es nie blutrünstig genug
sein ja ich glaube auch das ist ein
Thema
wir alle müssen sterben aber wir wissen
in der Regel nicht wann und wir wissen
in der Regel nicht wie das heißt es ist
die große angstvolle Unbekannte in
unserem Leben und diese große angstvoll
unbekannte löst sich für die meisten
Menschen nicht wirklich auf und das
heißt im Krimi wird das Schicksal eines
gewalttätigen Todes den wir in der Regel
ja alle nicht haben wollen sozusagen
vorweggenommen oder er wird uns
vorgeführt und zugleich werden wir
dadurch auch wieder entlastet also ich
glaube dass die diese Beschäftigung mit
mit Krimis in einer spannungsvollen
unterhaltsamen Art und Weise es ist ja
unterhaltsam irgendwie
eine Verharmlosung dessen ist dass wir
die Angst haben vor dem Thema Tod was
sehr in unserer Gesellschaft tabuisiert
wird und sehr am Rande stattfindet was
aber natürlich trotzdem jeden irgendwie
betrifft also Tatort ist zu Ende und du
weißt Gott sei Dank ich habe es doch
noch mal überlebt und Frauen mit Frauen
sind also man muss auch ehrlicherweise
sagen die meisten Tötungsdelikte
Geschehen ja von Männern untereinander
also Männer bringen sich ja
untereinander um mehrheitlich ja ähm wir
haben zwar Frauen also tötungs an Frauen
im Jahr aber das sind soziale nachfälle
Aspekte in der Regel und eigentlich
töten sich Männer mehrheitlich selber
also das Risiko getötet zu werden als
Mann untereinander ist sehr viel höher
als für eine Frau ich habe ihn im
letzten Buch glaube ich das liebe böse
diese Imagination mal gelesen sie machen
eine Übung eine eine imaginäre Übung und
sagen der erste Satz ist schon stellen
Sie sich einfach nur vor sie
ihre Existenz auf der Erde ist das
Ergebnis einer Vergewaltigung und wie
geht es dann weiter
Lilly könnte so eine Biografie
weitergehen genau ich dekliniere das
dann einfach durch weil ich ja ständig
mit netten Leuten zu tun habe deren
Existenz zu Beginn also sie werden
ungewollt gezeugt sie werden gewalttätig
gezeugt die die Mutter ist
möglicherweise Minderjährige ich
definiere das noch mal durch dass sie
sozusagen das Produkt eines Inzests sind
also der Vergewaltigung durch den Vater
oder wahlweise durch den
Lebensabschnittsgefährten der Frau kommt
jetzt nicht drauf an also sozusagen
transgenerationale
sexuelle missbrauchsituation eigene
Mutter sieht dich dann auch nicht als
das Kind das jetzt Opfer wurde sondern
ist eine rivalentin die Mutter ist
plötzlich die konkurrente nicht kenne
Milieus wo die Mutter selber die
eifersüchtige Konkurrentin ist mit in
Bezug auf die sexuellen missbrauchte
eigene Tochter so ja also es gibt ja
keinen Milieu kein Niveau dass man nicht
noch unterschreiten kann und dann spinne
ich das einfach mal versucht es
sprachlich so zu formulieren dass der
Leser die Leserin selber mal in die
Rolle gehen und sagt okay ich mache den
Faden mal mit und dann kann man sich
überlegen diese Mutter diese junge
Mutter die will das Kind natürlich nicht
haben das heißt sie versucht alles zu
tun um dieses Kind loszuwerden sie säuft
sind Drogen sie macht alles mögliche
aber dieses Kind sitzt da im Uterus fest
und und denkt nicht daran vorzeitig
abzugehen und dann kommt es zu dieser
Geburt dann haben sie aber wenn die
Mutter schon Alkohol getrunken hat
rumgenommen hat haben sie schon früh
kindlichen Hirnschaden die Hirn Reifen
ist schon beeinträchtigt das heißt die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie noch
irgendwie ein Abitur machen mit 1,3 ist
schon relativ gering Schädel
tv-formation
sie kommen schon also mit mit einem mit
einer optischen malformation auf die
Welt und dann genau sieht all die Mutter
hat getrunken sie haben mehr oder
minderale Schädigungen die natürlich
eine Rolle spielen für die Frage welchen
Lebensweg werden sie gehen ja mit der
Biografie werden sie nicht mehr
Bundeskanzler das kann man dann schon
sagen ja
das heißt dann haben sie die
gewaltserfahrung wir wissen über die
Epigenetik dass er nicht nur die Gene
also in einer unendlichen Mischung
vererbt werden sondern es werden
aktivitätszustände Aktivierungsmuster
von gehen vererbt man weiß dass bei
Mäusen zum Beispiel hat man einen
Versuch gemacht dass man Mäuse
Pfefferminzöl irgendwie Pfefferminz
gegeben hat und gleichzeitig hat man
Stromschläge
abgesetzt so und das heißt die
muttermaus hat immer kapiert okay und
sagt Pfefferminz riecht dann kriegt
gleich wieder einen getackert das war
bei den
Neugeborenen Mäusen
die haben
Stressreaktionen gezeigt nur wenn man
ihnen Pfefferminzöl zu schnuppern
gegeben hat ohne Strom ohne Strom das
heißt die Erfahrung der Mutter der
schwangeren erträchtigen Mutter hat sich
schon genetisch auf das auf das
Stresslevel auf den
stressregulations-elemente der der
kindermäuse übertragen und das ist bei
uns auch so wenn Sie in einem Mutterleib
heranwachsen wo die Mutter ständig Mal
trittiert wird misshandelt wird dann
werden sie als Kind im Mutterleib schon
darauf repariert dass sie in eine
feindselige Umwelt hineingeboren werden
Angstreaktion Stressreaktion das wird
alles schon angepasst auf ein Millionär
da geht's rund da ist es aus die kahl
und da sind wir jetzt im Ukraine das ist
das was sie dort fühlen sie können das
wirklich fühlen wenn sie mit jüngeren
Menschen sich danach austauschen jeder
ist misstrauisch das ist sozusagen die
unterste Stufe du hältst dann der Ampel
an du machst ein Foto und es ist nicht
die Frage woher kommt ihr seid die
Touristen was was fotografierst Du hier
sondern fotografierst du das um den
Russen ein Hinweis zu geben wo sie als
nächstes bombardieren sollen also dieses
Misstrauen das dann so eine Gesellschaft
reinkommt das ist unvorstellbar in
welcher Breite das passiert und dann das
andere das was sie sagen die Kinder die
sofort wissen Luftalarm das nächste ist
Tiefgarage oder das werden ihre
Enkelkinder Enkelkinder noch nicht im
Blut aber in der Gegend oder in den
genetischen scheitern genau diese
potenzielle gewaltserfahrung diese dies
nie zu wissen wann ist das nächste Mal
ultimativ eskaliert ja was macht das
muss immer Gesellschaft
das ist eine also ich verwende ja den
Begriff Traumatisierung immer sehr gerne
aber in dem Fall würde ich ihn
tatsächlich verwenden das ist eine
Traumatisierung über Generation und
normal befüllten wird es drei Generation
mindestens brauchen bis diese Traumata
in irgendeiner Weise von vergeben sind
verarbeitet werden
das ist eine eine tief eingebrannte
horizität die
sich hier möglicherweise bei vielen auch
erst dann wieder im Alter zeigt wenn
sozusagen frontane Kontrolle abnimmt und
zum Rahmen von demenzprozessen dann wäre
ich Kriegserlebnis auch auftauchen
werden das ist also ein
ich glaube das also für mich krank die
öffentliche Diskussion daran
dass wir das ganze Jahr sehr strategisch
betrachten aus dem Abstand den wir
glücklicherweise dankenswert damals
haben aber dass wir uns zu wenig konkret
glaube ich klar machen was diese Gewalt
tagtäglich bedeutet und wie wichtig es
ist diese politischen Fragen welche
Grenzen wo verlaufen und welches Land wo
ist das sind immer historische Fragen
gewesen die letzten Endes
auch über langwierige
Kommunikationsprozesse ja gelöst werden
könnten
aber das unmittelbare Kampfgeschehen ist
glaube ich eine Dimension die wir uns so
kaum vorstellen können und
glaube da müsste man sich ernsthaft
damit befassen ohne dass es wohl
juristisch wird und das finde ich immer
das wichtige wir können kaum juristische
zusammengefasst alles in dem schönen
Satz von ihr Manuel Kant der gesagt hat
das Schlimme an den Kriegen ist dass sie
mehr böse Menschen schaffen als die
Lehrer hinwegnehmen ja genau also Frau
Sami vielen Dank
es war Aufschluss
gemacht genau dieses Thema und und zeigt
auch sozusagen für mich normal ähm wie
dünn dieser Film ist sozusagen der
Zivilisation letzten Endes ist und das
die Tatsache dass wir schon so lange das
Glück haben in einer friedlichen Phase
unseres Landes
leben und zu sein dass die unmittelbar
offenbar dazu führt dass die
mordstatistik deutlich nach unten geht
ja genau so sollte es ja sein sollten
wir sollten jeden Preis versuchen zu
erhalten das ist der Punkt mit
friedlichen Mitteln in der Gesellschaft
darum kämpfen dass es so hat also vielen
Dank wir danken
[Musik]
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF